hello Doug Walker here if you see me
drinking this I'm fighting off a cold or
something or cough and I just hit the
bum reviews already my voice is gonna be
a little hoarse uh but you don't care
about that you're here to hear about
interstellar and before I talk about
interstellar I should make something
pretty clear because there's probably
gonna be a rant in this uh just know
that whenever I get like really
emotional and waving my arms and stuff
like that um I'm not lying and in some
way I'm not playing it up either I mean
I am a touch but it is my opinion but
it's it's not to be taken too seriously
I mean this is this is for fun this is a
geek talking about geeky things and it's
fun to explode about something that you
kind of know is not gonna have a huge
effect on your life really but um but
but that's part of the internet that's
part of the fun of it um but yeah don't
let it um cuz like I see my fans and
they're fine and everything and they
seem to be very friendly and stuff
everyone's why you see someone leave a
comment and you're just like are you
okay unlike some people that just like
that's like it keeps them up at night
and just don't let my opinion or
anyone's opinion of a movie like unless
you made it and even then I kind of
argue don't let that leave a mark either
uh so just know that this is for fun
it's geeks being geeky just don't like I
said don't lose sleep over it uh if you
do probably nobody does but I I care um
so with that said let's have some fun
here let's talk about interstellar um I
went in really not wanting to see this
movie I want to see the the new Disney
flick the B hero six um but I I have
just nice ember coming up and I figured
this would be a bigger hit more people
would see it so the really fast quick
you know couple second review if you
don't want to wade through all this is
um I the the first third is okay the
second third awful like fucking blows
and then the last third is actually
pretty decent like it's pretty solid um
and if
going into this like you're not looking
to analyze a movie or you're not like
you're looking to just sort of turn your
brain off enjoy a film um
this film will probably be too long for
you it is fucking three hours and it
does not need to be three hours but I'll
go into that in a minute but if you're
just a common whatever Lee just want to
see a film not saying good it's it's
probably serviceable it'll just be
really long with a lot of slow parts
that are really not needed uh so that's
my real quick just couple second summary
there uh the actual film itself um I've
gone on and on making fun of uh
Crispin Dolan recently which is so funny
cuz he's directed like you know one of
my favorite movies The Dark Knight I
love The Dark Knight and I'm not a fan
of The Dark Knight Rises I'm not fan of
Man of Steel as maybe you know I know
you did dark man steel but he's he's
thumb prints all over it
um so if this movie comes out and I sort
of went in saying okay just don't be the
common view or don't think about it just
to just watch you try to get into it and
the first third has a lot of Nolan isms
I mean just a lot of explaining and a
lot of exposition and you know you're
just sitting there like you know what
what does it mean to be there's well
what does mean that the world what is it
just just we'll get to that in a second
but so but the world is being taken over
by these giant dust clouds um that
really people notice a little too late
like a playing a baseball game like oh
no it does class it's already like
gigantic how could you miss this but it
if you want to read this for like the
scientific side of it I mean this is
like gravity mixed with prometheus in
how authentic the science even as a
movie go is I mean it's like don't even
try it is beyond ridiculous but that's
not what I was there for and I don't
think it's well a lot of people are
there for they're there for the
emotional experience and the first third
despite how talky it is is actually okay
uh
John Lithgow is the grandfather of
Matthew McConaughey who I didn't
recognize her for say he's really for a
bit part he's pretty damn good um and
these little knocks are being done
through the house and books are falling
a certain way and his daughter thinks
it's a ghost that's interesting cuz I
really didn't think we're gonna do this
angle okay and I kinda was not gonna be
a ghost but whatever the the dust is
falling in a certain way and she thinks
it's Morse code
smart kid but okay you know and for
whatever reason Matthew McConaughey just
buys and freezes like there's no goes no
goes and then Sully like I think you're
right and like he is coordinates let's
follow these coordinates like just
really kind of out of the blue does it
but again out its Nolan ok whatever so
so if Ali's coordinates finds and as a
secret location um and pretty much goes
there and finds that they're creating a
mission to get humanity off the earth
you know like you'd see in the trailers
and there's a plan a and a plan B plan a
is to go through this wormhole that
apparently will lead to three different
worlds like three different planets and
they want to repopulate that okay Plan B
if I'm right cuz by count there's so
much science mumbo-jumbo it's hard to
follow I think they like either have
embryos or something frozen uh that's
gonna like repopulate mankind so I don't
know it's let the people under die start
anew I don't know if they're just gonna
do each other or whatever or they're
some of the frozen embryos I don't know
I'm sure was explained you know just
really fast and I missed it that's
probably a dumb thing for me but you
know it's either let everybody die or
get them off the planet that's pretty
much it so Matthew McConaughey though he
just stumbles on to this NASA place
they're like you're the only pilot who
can fly this way you fly this far it's
just a couple wait a minute what if he
didn't stumble on to that what would you
still find him and it's just the mother
of all coincidences so he agrees of
course and he has to leave is his kids
behind and they're and there's even a
sign apparently that the daughter went
through the North co s s stay is a
that's nothing it just led me to the
location of NASA I'm sure that doesn't
mean anything
yeah so he deal still decides to go and
it's one of those things where it's a
time difference where he can be gone an
hour but for us it's like umpteen years
or something uh so he goes with um Anne
Hathaway the bag filmer from American
Beauty and uh and I know some other
people I can't remember um but but he
goes Weezer right astronauts into into
the wormhole which is pretty cool the
wormhole is a pretty neat thing I saw it
on IMAX that was really neat and comes
out the other end there's like this
choice about which plan to go through
science mumbo-jumbo he says maybe we can
go down there first I can get some data
that we need and come back so we can go
to this other planet they try that
things go wrong against a giant plant of
water they lose an astronaut and I think
they even lose the data and they find
the astronauts I said before going blah
blah blah so now they've been gone the
equivalent of 23 years and the kids are
grown up and that's the point up to that
point I was like I'm okay like I'm okay
with this movie this is gonna be spoiler
free after this so don't worry um but
after that something happens with the
pacing and we just go total total Noland
mode total well now we need to go this
far are we gonna go this part what does
it mean to go to that part what I did -
blah blah blah fucking talking fucking
talking and a million goddamn things
happening that just get more and more
ridiculous uh first of all these planets
this is not based on anything this is an
original story you know which you don't
see often and it's like what do you do
for your new worlds free planets not one
three fucking planets that they can go
to and what do they do they have one
that's all water one that's a Canyon or
a desert we see at the end and then what
a fucking shock snowy mountains continue
match snowy mountains in a Christopher
Nolan film by God I mean it's it's like
okay so in in uh insomnia it's like okay
fair enough yet to be in a place where
you can't sleep in Alaska
you know the did son the night goes away
okay that makes sense uh in dart Batman
Begins well that's a little weird why
why is he go to the snowy mountains but
okay and it's like okay they go to space
and they find out what the fuck are you
talking about what is your fetish with
snowy mountains this is your in space
you know and and all you give us is
water mountains and sand you know the
mountains okay you put them upside down
that was neat
you make the you make the cloud snowy
mountains somehow they crash into it
it's Isis and whatever but by God makes
us know purple and make the water green
I don't care and make the sands biking
you can do anything you're Christopher
Nolan you made up team put five billion
dollars just on the Dark Knight bones
alone and these are your new imaginative
worlds I come on its side by and to do
that that really pissed me off I'm sorry
so that's one thing uh then they come
across this other the this other
astronaut played by Matt Damon I ain't
giving anything away with that and again
without giving away too much he pretty
much just he's there just to spew out
Nolan but err I mean just like you know
the reason we don't send robots instead
of people cuz there's a sassy robot in
this I kid you not I remind you to come
back to that people who can't remind me
at all uh you know he's like the reason
we can't send people instead of robots
because humans have the human element
what will you think of before you die
you will think of your child's he and
that will push you to the grave and he
just tossing this throughout the whole
time there's a fight scene in this
really realistic sci-fi film that you
know we're like children die and stuff
like that but you know that there's a
fight scene in spacesuits because we're
that realistic and they're just like you
know even as he's doing this he's like
you know you don't understand it's the
challenge it's the world that we're
finding - have you ever thought about
it's like shut up god so and so okay and
it kinda gets like I sigh I don't want
to draw too specific into but there's a
scene where again they're trying to make
this
really realistic and like you know this
one of the characters dies actually in
the middle of a monologue you don't
understand sometimes there's a poem and
he dies and I just I almost like busted
a gut laughing cuz I'm like oh my god
like these she couldn't even finish his
nolan monologue against Nolan law I'll
call it that and it just killed me cuz
it's like they're talking so much they
don't even see what they should be doing
so uh and after that okay so you get all
this exposition all this talking all
this philosophical nonsense all this
teaching all this lecturing constantly
in the middle of this don't mean like
the meat of the film and there's one
scene where this if they perform this
stunt it's like the space station is
spinning out of control
Matthew McConaughey has to pilot the
space ship under it to try and get under
and hook it up while it's spinning and
hook it up in this realistic gritty dark
adult sci-fi film where he can hook this
up I mean even like Star Wars pilots are
being like that shit ain't real that
would not happen you know and we shall
torpedo when a Death Star blow it up
somehow but that shit would not happen
okay that that makes no sense but but
here's the thing okay so they go and
they hook up and it's like there's a
quiet moment and Anne Hathaway just
bursts out laughing you know cuz it was
so intense and so crazy and by conahey
goes whoa now for my next trick and they
both laugh and I'm like that was nice
that they were they were just you know
laughing after this incredibly intense
scene but literally like two seconds
later whoo oh my god now we're being
sucked into the black hole okay you go
over the vortex you and I just wanted to
get up grab the movie and go stop it
stop it I wanted to slap it and go shut
up just shut up okay Christopher Nolan
movie I want to talk to your main
character but kind of hey c'mere LBL
yeah and I'll save McConaughey I want
you for a second
no not a second because you do that
sometimes in this film to be fair I want
you for like a solid minute
at least just to talk like a human being
and he'd be like oh well it's all about
preserving laughs and I want preferred
to laugh and my kid no no no just just
talk like a human being
so but the space station is about to
explode and we're gonna it no no that
that's exposition that's explaining well
sometimes in life you'll know that fills
just be a human being okay just talk
like a person a fucking person but but
that doesn't have anything to do with
the mission and the story no no but this
is how we relate to you this is how we
want you to live we get inside because
we say oh this person is a person like
us you're one of us and that way we
don't want to see you die because when
you're just saying space mumbo-jumbo and
science mumbo-jumbo we don't give a shit
because we don't know who you are you're
just exposition but I talked about my
wife dying and that that's exposition
okay you're explaining your emotions
you're not feeling them now please just
for a second talk about anything that's
not a lecture not teaching not
philosophy not exposition not any that
just be a human being I'd be like well
up now know it Cubs
sure been losing a lot and the fact
that's good that's good anything else I
don't know I guess deep inside it makes
me feel no no don't do that just keep
well we know we can connect the dots
that the Cubs losing a lot makes you
feel bad talk some more uh you know I
don't really believe in curses but uh
you know that Billy go things sometimes
you gotta wonder right right yeah yeah
you know at times almost think about
becoming a White Sox fan cuz it's how
you feel there's no hope but it's like
you know whatever that they can pull
through there could be a time do you
want me to go into why I feel and the
psychological implement no no you're
you're fine we we get it you were a
person there you were human being and
you you didn't explain you didn't teach
you didn't lecture you didn't do any of
that you just taught and you felt and it
was real can you give us more of that
well I'll try but it's the script it's
the fucking script
I am so sick of that talking in these
movies especially when they come so
close to having real moments salut
though with that said after God three
hours of this and science mumbo-jumbo
and there's a scene where Matt Damon is
going into the ship and it's like what
needs to happen could only take I mean
you could shoot this in like a minute
you could chop it down to a minute but
nowhere to show every single process he
goes through we have to show him looking
around and figuring in monologue anymore
and it's like just this movie is three
hours that doesn't need to be make it
too easily - if there is so much
nonsense that happens in the middle that
any could have been more creative if you
are gonna go this long or be you could
have just traded it out for letting
people talk the opening is very good
like when he leaves his daughter behind
he's gonna go into space they don't show
any of him training or getting suited up
right he's just going into space and
it's a very effective edit of him
driving away and you hear the countdown
there's the daughter crying in the
music's building and he's driving as a 3
2 1 blast-off mates in the suit and he's
going up wonderful that was great you
know it's moments like that that don't
make me like hate this film you know cuz
I guess it starts off well and it comes
back to that at the end uh you know
again through like a lot of mother of
all coincidences if you want more watch
the bum review on it um but it works ok
and you get visually interesting again
you know there's this um I won't say
what he goes yeah I will he goes into
the black hole they bring it up like as
soon as they go into space and because
apparently in this movie he doesn't ask
questions about saving the world you
know days before he's gonna go do it he
has seconds before is a yeah these are
astronauts you said they came back right
it's like some of them and it's like
you're asking this like two seconds
before you're going into this goddamn
thing so as soon as you hear black hole
yes but be too dangerous oh well I'm
sure they're not gonna do that
of course he goes into the black hole
and the way they represent is very
creative very unique very stylized uh
and it's actually again they explain a
lot but it's it bounces out okay the
emotion is there uh and I think that's
what this movie needed maybe even wanted
to be it was supposed to be this
emotional journey but there's just too
much other shit getting in the way
that's not interesting and long-winded
and you know you you could have cut out
an hour you didn't need the Matt Damon
something you didn't need three planets
what's wrong with one you didn't even
need there's an extra little ending at
the end with Anne Hathaway and it's like
movie wasn't about that
you know I won't give it away but it
wasn't about that you know it was about
the the daughter and the astronaut and
you know whenever I came back to that it
was good uh you know and characters
would flip on a dime as well he has a
son in this that suddenly at the end
he's just a jerk I mean it's just like
you know no I won't do this and the
daughter wants to go back to the room
where all the supernatural stuff
happened twenty three years later and
say that maybe there was something to
that what the fuck okay you're now like
this uber genius who knows this Morse
code was real you know it led you to
NASA it even fell out stay you know your
father hasn't come back and he's like
you all go back up to your room no no no
the too many memories fuck you it's the
world okay I mean it's like this this
woman has a thing for the fact that the
world is at stake even though he's
trying she's trying to figure out how
you know this formula or whatever is
she's mad at her dad for leaving to save
the world and then she's like no I can't
go into that room cuz it gives me too
many memories but it's the fucking world
and architecting your life to the world
it makes no sense but who okay that's my
rant that's my rant on the movie uh I
can't do this backwards where I say at
the beginning who would probably like
this uh in terms of who wouldn't like it
um probably over thinkers and people
that want a well-paced movie
if by god if I could go in and just like
erase all the middle like he goes on
Spacey goes into the wormhole and then
you just put in like shit happens and
then you cut to him in the black hole
it's like oh it would be great I knew
would have had problems but it would
have been pretty good but no we had to
go through what everyone thinks makes
this big epic which is length and a lot
of dialogue it doesn't have to be you
know it's like I just want to sit
Christopher Nolan down I just want to
say okay I want you to watch the three
films here I want you to watch Pulp
Fiction I want you to watch Goonies and
I want you to watch the original Batman
which I know you've seen I'm sure you've
seen all those movies I want you to
watch them and ask why you care about
those people what are they not doing
that you do all the time and that's
constantly explaining the explanation
Castley talking about how they're
feeling constantly wording everything
instead they're just characters Batman
we saw it again on the big screen a
couple weeks ago and I was just like I
was thinking if Nolan did this the scene
with Michael Kim and Kim Basinger on
their first date everything is explained
not just visually but in very few words
but those words are so perfectly chosen
and the actors are so good and you feel
it you don't have to be told you don't
have to be spoon-fed this shit and so
same thing with Goonies the kids are
just being kids for fiction that the
these terrible people are being cool
guys they're just talking they're
talking about Big Macs and Burger King
and stuff like that I mean seems like
that are so important and those are not
in Christopher Nolan films I feel they
are they can be like these grand
masterpieces it's like just cut it all
down you know just just simplify just
get to what you need and you can make
these gigantic epic you know timeless
films you know but it's I don't know
it's they're just so much talking in
them and I see a great talent who's made
these incredible groundbreaking
innovations with like memento and like
it's a dark night even Batman Begins uh
the inception visually even through some
ideas as far as a mainstream movie goes
you know
interesting uh but yeah it's like he's
just kind of caught in this net you know
that like this seemed to work so I need
to do more of this but it's a you don't
just you know it's the kiss effect keep
it simple stupid you know I love that
phrase you know there is a time to talk
there is a time to do all this but just
it's not all the time you know just just
keep it simple
um so yeah yeah sorry I said the ranch
is over I guess I was my second rant um
so if if you want to see a film where
you don't think too hard but it has
right just enough emotion I mean this
this will do okay for you it's just
really long and your butt will hurt at
the end of it somebody's gonna take that
clip and do terrible things I know but
nevertheless um it's just yeah that's
the one thing I think is gonna affect
most people they're gonna be like damn
was that lengthy that was a super long
movie um I heard people talking
afterwards in their lay no no that was
good like they sort of like the kind of
twist at the end which is like a not
even halfway through I'm like oh it's
this um but I'm still interested cuz I
was like it like I like the relationship
between the father and the daughter um
and yeah that I think you can kind of
get an idea whether or not you'll like
it if you're if you're an over-thinker
you'll hate it you'll totally hate it if
you're somewhere in between you'll be
exactly that you'll be somewhere in
between as much as I rant and rave about
this um I say it because I really do
want to see great stuff come out of this
guy cuz of great stuff has and it's like
it's he's always so close with it but
then it's like he throws in all this
other you know long-winded stuff that's
not needed it's like you know it's a
novel and it's not a novel and make it a
movie you know don't talk about just
show it and there are there is some
pretty imagery in this sometimes
especially when they go to Saturn um but
yeah that there it need to be more of a
visual medium and it just needed to be a
lot shorter though that's my that's my
self that I said at the end I'm
repeating here so uh hopefully that
helps guys um I have no idea what the
feedback on this is gonna be every time
I talk about a Nolan film like people
really freeze their fish me whether I
like it or hate it so um yeah guys
that's about it I will talk to you later
and there will be review of be hero six
in Disney summer so don't worry about
that uh that's about it and I'll talk to
you later
take it